If you go for this defense where
you use languages that are safe,
obviously buffer overflow
becomes impossible because of
all the checks the language is going
to do, so we set bounds checks.
So the checks have to be done at
run time rather than you doing that
explicitly in the code that you write,
that language is doing for you.
So, why don't we use these kind
of languages for everything?
Well more and more we're doing that but
one draw back with these kind
of languages typically is that,
that's going to be either
some sort of performance
degradation because we just talked
about the checks that had to be done.
And they force you to do certain
things in a certain way.
So flexibility that generally you have
you have with low level programming
languages goes away.
So if you're looking for really
performance or all the flexibility in
the world, maybe that's why you don't
use these languages that do this work
for you to make the buffer
overflow kind of problems go away.